أوه ، لدينا موقف أمامنا ،
قف ، قف ، لا ، لا ، نحن نسير على
الجانب الخطأ من الطريق ، قف ، قف ،
لا ، لا ، يريد أن
يصطدم بالشاحنة
[موسيقى]
هذا نموذج تسلا  3.
لذلك نحن نقوم بتشغيل الإصدار
التجريبي الكامل للقيادة الذاتية ،
حسنًا ، أصبحت السيارة الآن رسميًا
نوعًا ما من الناحية الفنية التي تقود نفسها بنفسها ،
لقد كان ذلك منعطفًا حادًا حقًا
حاولت السيارة تحقيقه ، لقد حصلنا على
موقف أمامنا ، أليس كذلك؟
حسنًا ، ما كان أمامنا للتو هو
شاحنة صعودية قادمة إلى حارتنا ، كان لدينا
رجل أمامنا يحمل دراجة شحن
لتجنب اصطدام الرجل على الدراجة ،
ويبدو أن السيارات تريد أن تضعنا مباشرة
في صعود عملاق  الشاحنة التي أفضل
عدم اصطدامها بشاحنة UPS اليوم ، لذا
فقد استلمتها يبدو أنها بحاجة إلى
مقاطعة كل بضع كتل
أو أحيانًا إذا كانت السيارة مترددة
قليلاً ،
يجب أن أتدخل أيضًا ، يجب أن تكون
مستعدًا لتولي المهمة  في أي وقت الآن هذا
يمثل تحديًا ، لا ، نحن نسير على
الجانب الخطأ من الطريق
[موسيقى]
نحن  لا نحاول إفساد هذه السيارة ،
فنحن لا نحاول أن نضحك
من تشويق إيلون ماسك ، هذه ليست
النقطة التي نحاول حقًا أن نرى
كيف تتعامل معها القيادة في مدينة حتى الآن ،
فلا بأس.
السير في طريق طبيعي مستقيم تمامًا
، لا يوجد الكثير من
المشاة هنا ، وعندما تسير
في طريق مستقيم مع عدد
قليل من المشاة
، يبدو أن السيارة في الواقع تسير على ما يرام ،
فنحن نتعامل مع الحد الأقصى للسرعة
الذي تعرفه  نحن لا نصطدم بأي
شيء يمكن للسيارة أن تراه المخاريط يمكن للسيارة أن ترى
الشاحنات التي يمكن للسيارة رؤيتها حتى المشاة
على الجانب الآخر من الشارع
قد لا تكون المشكلة تمامًا هنا إنها
معرفة ما يجب القيام به في المواقف الصعبة ،
الأشياء التي تعلمها التجربة
نحن نسير في شارع فلاتبوش في
بروكلين حيث يقود آلاف السائقين
كل يوم سائقون بشريون ، وهذا
هو الشريان الرئيسي من خلال
شاحنات نقل الركاب في بروكلين ، حيث يذهب الناس إلى
وظائفهم ، ويقوم الكثير من السائقين البشر بهذا
كل يوم ، لذا  أود أن نكون قادرين على
التعامل معها بشكل جيد ولكننا
نتوقف في التقاطع لا الآن ،
سنذهب مرة أخرى ، ماذا عن ذلك
وليس لدينا ضوء أخضر
والسيارة تتردد في قولها لا شيء صحيح
استدر ولكن يمكننا أن نذهب مباشرة وهذا هو
المكان الذي نريد أن نذهب إليه ، نريد أن نسير بشكل
مستقيم ، أقف على استعداد
للتدخل ،
آمل أن أفعل ذلك بسرعة كافية الآن ،
سيكون هذا تحديًا لدينا
سياج أمامنا ، قف ،
سيارة  كادت أن تصطدم بالسياج هناك حيث
أغلقت ممرًا للانعطاف ولكن
كان من المفترض أن تتحرك السيارة إلى المسار التالي على
أي حال لأننا نسير في اتجاه مستقيم
ولم يكن الأمر متجهًا إلى حد كبير
نحو تلك الأسوار لذا اضطررت إلى
تولي القيادة  هناك ،
هذا رسميًا ليس جاهزًا حقًا
للاستهلاك العام ، يعاني الكثير من الناس من
مشاكل مع هذا يسمى
القيادة الذاتية الكاملة أولاً وقبل كل شيء ليس
القيادة الذاتية بالكامل ، يجب أن أجلس هنا إذا
كانت ذاتية القيادة بالكامل كما وعدت.
تأخذ قيلولة أثناء القيادة على طول
قف ولكن  لقد صدمنا المكابح
هناك والآن هذه الشاحنة الكبيرة
ستذهب وسنرى ما إذا كنا
سنذهب حول الشاحنة الكبيرة ،
سأعطي
القليل من خوذة الغاز ، لا كلا ، لا
يريدها أن تصطدم بالشاحنة ، لذا
سنستخدم سائقًا بشريًا للتجول في
الشاحنة ، ولا أقود سيارة تسلا كل يوم ،
أنا متقلب قليلاً ، وسأعترف تمامًا
بذلك ، لذا فأنا أتولى أكثر من
شخص  من اعتاد على أداء النظام
وبسبب ذلك ، ربما أقوم بتحريف الأشياء
قليلاً ولكن هذا هو تأثير المراقب
لأنه يشبه إلى حد ما
تعليم المراهق كيفية القيادة
وأنت تشاهد دائمًا أنك
تنتظرك دائمًا  لا تعرف أبدًا متى قد تجرب
شيئًا جديدًا وهذا هو المكان الذي
يأتي منه القلق منك تعلم أنه
يبدو أنه يجعل جميع السائقين يشعرون بالضيق ،
من الأشخاص الذين يقفون خلفنا ، إنه الأشخاص الذين
يفرطون
الآن أنا لا أقول إن سيارة ذاتية القيادة حقًا
لن تحدث أبدًا  لكن
أعتقد في هذه المرحلة أننا ما زلنا على بعد سنوات
[موسيقى]